you're going to kill me and a lot of
people out there are going to kill me
I've never seen any Star Wars never I've
never seen any of them well no after a
couple years it hadn't happened and then
I kind of real it really upsets people
like people get really angry it's really
kind of funny I kind of don't watch it
now just because it infuriates people so
much like how how have you never watched
any any Star Wars and I just kind of
want to see how long I can make it now
it particularly infuriates my husband so
I've really held off and it's kind of
nice having it in my back pocket like
should life ever get a bit dull I know
that I've got Star Wars you do you know
who Luke Skywalker's father is oh that
one I know you do know yeah L I am your
father isn't it Darth Vader it's Darth
Vader when we did w for Wall Street you
would get angry at me all the time any
time I'd mention any movie I hadn't seen
he'd be like how have you not seen
citizen K how can you work in this
industry and not seen citizen K I'm like
I just got to he to this industry